thanks for the nice intro and glad to be
here and talk and to share a little bit
about what we've been working on in the
open-source community and how we
collaborate some with Google cloud team
if you're a designer in the room close
your eyes for one second because I'm
about to do presentation blasphemy there
we go now you can open up we're on the
new sites so I've here today I'm going
to talk a little bit about a topic
around notebooks and kind of smelling a
little bit you don't know notebooks are
what they are and then how we've been
using this to kind of move notebooks
closer to a production tool and make it
usable with this with a technology
called paper mill so I think the bio
intro for me is what's already there I
work on the big data orchestration team
at Netflix and so that what that really
means I'll explain in a minute and yeah
so I've done this talk once before so
hopefully this will go really nice and
we'll be able to dive a little deeper
into things and I'm excited to connect
with you all afterwards and see what
your thoughts are ok so to start off
we're gonna talk a little bit about what
the heck does the data platform team do
this is surprisingly mysterious even
among data platform team members
sometimes so give a little bit outline
of at least at Netflix what a day of
platform team does so the data platform
team is really focused around building
tools and services they get out of the
way of users doing their job so you have
things on the on the left side of the
slide here where you maybe have events
or user inputs or system metrics and lo
this thing the characters to this fake
idea called Big Data all idea gets
collected up and you need somehow to get
that to the end result of making
business decisions around reports or
delivering information individuals or
making data models for AI and at the end
of the day the user just wants to be
able to get as a data engineer or
machine learning developer they want to
be able to use this data to make these
outcomes so the data platform services
that Netflix is really about building
the tools so this is easier and easier
for those users to do their job and so
we do a lot of kind of integrate
of many different systems and platforms
and tools so that they don't impede a
user's like being able to achieve that
so what that kind of boils down to is
they platform team you know it opens
doors just not that door all the things
I'm going to talk about today are
actually in open source projects so this
is around Jupiter open source ecosystem
and the interact ecosystem they're both
sort of building different tools around
notebooks and they're like in are
compatible they're not like different
projects in that hole and all these
things been contributed by Netflix and
by Google cloud to get integrations into
their platforms and to their tools
or just as a general usability for
everyone so real quick how many of you
know what a notebook is ever used a
notebook how many know the difference
see a jupiter notebook and another
notebook is cool we got like four people
so i'm gonna talk a little bit what the
difference is there and for those of you
haven't used a notebook kind of what the
heck are they so in the most basic vein
a notebook is you'll see something like
this is an interface almost i make say
this is a notebook this is an interface
that basically gives you a broken down
like chunk of code and documentation and
logs that are sent and received from
some remote rebel or local rebel so you
have some engine that's gonna execute
code or execute documentation requests
and return back some display and
outcomes of what happened so here in
this example you see how it's really
basic notebook it's gonna import an
image and it's gonna render that image
in the notebook and then print out some
text really super basic stuff but you
can see this is sort of a grouping of
code and execution in a nice kind of
flowing manner and you see this is a
different interface for notebooks at the
same technology and these are all
jupiter notebook interfaces and in
particular the benefits of using this
technology lie around the fact that you
have code log documentation execution
results all kind of in the same document
and that this document is shareable to
others this means it's really useful for
iterative development
it's really handy for sharing results
with colleagues and it lets you
integrate various API calls in one
central place that's kind of well-formed
a little bit about what what what's on
this page what does it represent what's
it mean so you have things like a status
or save indicator in the upper right or
something about the connection to a
kernel which is what's actually
executing your code do you have to kind
of standard menu items any of things
called code cells here so you see this
thing I've outlined is it code cell it's
a it's a chunk of text which represents
code in a particular language or
framework Jupiter notebooks in
particular actually language agnostic
though most the times you'll see them in
Python because that's probably a popular
kernel type and so here you see there's
some basic Python code maybe I want to
load in a model and assert that my model
has some version on it and they maybe
want to pull something out of that model
and display it so the second part that's
really useful in notebooks is availa or
graphs or images or HTML right inside
the same place for you to find the code
so you don't have to jump between
systems to kind of see results the other
really neat thing about notebooks is you
can rerun just one cell so it keeps
track of the state as they're executing
so you can run everything linearly in a
row like we're gonna do later or if you
were iterating try to figure out what
the act where the display you're trying
to get actually is you can try and look
for it run the cell if it fails try
changing it but you run the cell you
don't have to rerun the model load that
happen in the cell before it's already
been loaded and you're just iterating on
like a live code session we talked a
little bit about already kind of wind
here but mainly it's this kind of
familiar interface for for exploring
data and exploring problems so how is
this work a bit so in the Jupiter space
independent of other types of notebooks
the Jupiter space actually is really bet
to finding the protocols about how to
communicate between the code executor
and the front-end or the client that
actually wants to execute this so you'll
get something like this where we have
some users on the upper left and those
users
yes up the left for you as well is this
in the upper left and they also be using
some sort of Jupiter UI and they have
some document an IP MIB file which
represents the notebook and then they're
interacting through the UI with a
Jupiter
server which is communicating to the
code executor called it colonel and it
basically just forwards a quest back and
forth from the colonel on your behalf
and then there's a protocol that colonel
follow so that any client in any
different UI or interface could do the
same thing with their own like display
the difference between there and sort of
other notebooks by the way is that back
in a second
other notebooks oftentimes bundle the
colonel and the server together so
they'll have like a kind of just the API
layer to the client and they won't
emphasize how you actually execute which
means it's harder and harder for if you
want to make a new type of kernel to
just execute a new type of language or
if you want to make a new UI you have to
sort of reinvent many more things here
the kernel and the UI api's are all
independent units they are all well
specs so you'll see many many different
flavors of UI and extensions like the
ones we're talking about today and that
gives Jupiter a notebook space of kind
of advantage over many of the other
notebook options so we're talk a little
about why these came about and how how
come people use notebooks especially if
you've never used one and someone's like
I really need to have this notebook in
production you're like what is this
thing
where'd it come from where it came from
was this ability to kind of explore and
analyze data and kind of find a result
so it's really handy for data scientists
workflows where I need to load some data
that's expensive to load and I need to
iterate on a model over and over and
over again and maybe I don't know what
my end codes gonna look like maybe I
don't even know what I should be doing
yet so it makes a really nice way to
explore without having to recompute all
the very expensive aspects of your code
and this kind of comes into like the
fact that this makes some really nice
qualities for certain workflows it also
lets you record outputs and it's also an
easy to modify tool I can share this
notebook somebody else they can
reproduce what I'm doing and they can
modify it slightly without having to
understand a lot of systems I can just
ship them a file and they have that
reproducibility but there's a lot of
things that make engineering teams kind
of frustrated with trying to move these
from a development cycle and the
scratchpad into a real production system
and some of these things are around a
lack of history if you accidently edit a
cell and save it doesn't tell you what
you edited it
it's hard sometimes they go find out
what you actually did especially close
your browser or something else um they
can be really difficult to test
traditionally so someone will write a
thousand lines of code hand it over the
wall and ask for ten thousand lines of
code now hey make this run in production
like hello I don't know how this works
or if it's gonna work reliably it's also
a mutable document so you're always
editing it in place and traditional UI's
and it becomes kind of hard to like
collaborate on in this sense because two
people trying to edit that document the
same time you can run into a lot of
issues without extensions on the
protocols so one thing we did at Netflix
was try to fill some of these gaps
we had a ton of users using notebooks
and the the things we saw was that
instead of trying to push those users
away from using notebooks said oK we've
got a sizable number of users who all
love working in this environment and
they're having a lot of friction in pain
moving from that to the systems that are
already in place so I'm gonna have to
rewrite all the work they did or had
someone else rewrite all the work they
did in another place in the same exact
pattern they already solved so some
things we wanted to do is really help
with you know improving the the fact
that these notebooks aren't version so
it's hard to figure out what you
actually ran in particular time a
mutable state and it can't really be
template it always creates a human to go
edit the the you from the UI and change
a variable to rerun it which is not a
very programmatic pattern but something
to really wanted to preserve was like
results linked to right next to the code
good visuals the ease of sharing you
know these are the benefits and we
didn't want to move away from them so we
worked on this library and the open
source called paper mill and paper mill
is in this github project called
interact which have to hold on to
utilities and tools around notebooks
particularly Jupiter differs from a high
level it store works this way it's a
program which runs like a client much
like a UI would and it's going to take
something as an input notebook in some
path either
that's three in google cloud store in
your local file system it's gonna
parameterize and run that notebook and
then it's going to output it to an
output location that's independent of
the input so in this case we maybe have
four different runs we've run where
we've run the same to look for times
with a different run each time
and how about this look in code so it's
actually a really simple interface you
don't have to like get really
complicated with it here we're gonna do
some examples where we run paper mill
against some Google Cloud paper mail
demo with some input notebook and we're
gonna basically output it to a new place
and here we're just running the notebook
you verbatim as is we said hey we want
to run this notebook so let's pay for
meal doing it's actually executing the
whole notebook and the end from the
beginning to the very last cell and as
each cell executes sif no heirs occur it
continues to the next cell and as a cell
executes it's saving the outcome into
the output location so you get
incremental results as it's going and it
also can log out live what's actually
happening even if you have some
interruptions the middle of a cell or
some hardware guys but if you run this
where we have some output round of the
demo we have demos outs you see like a
folder a new Google cloud that has these
output runs maybe you're running once
for each day so you put the date into
your output path and now you actually
can see history what you ran every
single day you didn't mutate the input
you actually your output is isolated
from your input so you get some nice and
beautiful big guarantees you also get
some version history in the sense like
if you're running things you can see you
historically what you actually executed
but that isn't where we stopped because
one of the other things that we can't do
is we can't go in and edit like a human
and change of parameter or a variable
inside the notebook and then expect that
notebook to run so when someone gives us
a notebook we actually need the ability
of the template size it which is AB
parameters so in this case you can see
we're going to run this input notebook
and pretend this is a notebook which
goes and maybe counts the number of
clicks by device in a certain region for
some website you've maybe heard of the
the notebook that you're running we
would have this default parameter cell
in here where you would identify this is
my default you can set the region to us
devices the PC so if I were to run this
notebook without paper mill it would run
and say hey I'm gonna count everything
in the US that was a PC that did it
click on the website but then when we
parameterize it in this way with paper
mill you're gonna see that we've
overwritten region devices by inserting
another code cell so the way paper mill
works is it'll generate your inputs
create a code cell
those inputs and inject that into the
notebook as though if it were a user
input and then when it runs your outcome
actually just has that right in this
code so when you read it there's gonna
be the cell with the comment saying
parameters and all the parameters that
got injected by the system on your
behalf and also like you have to be
exiting this from from Python excuse me
you can also execute this in command
line which is actually probably more
common pattern though if you're trying
to extend it you'll want to extend
things in Python but here you can see
the same as that command where we did
this Google Cloud notebook input output
path we can do the same thing because
Manly I'm just saying papermill as a CLI
which wraps that other call and then you
can pass in parameters in any sort of
JSON format or as like individual key
values technically - wise for yamo so
you can give it the ml as well though
here we're passing do something so let's
do maybe what would this actually look
like if I were calling it on the command
line so it'd be something like this I
run that command that we ran you gonna
see the print out okay I'm grabbing an
input notebook from here I'm going to an
output you see this progress bar going
that kind of prints out progress is
going in the rate at which it's
processing it's configurable which of
these things you want to render by
default but it gives you some like
basics about what's actually executing
as it goes and you can even put in a log
mode so it'll print out all the logs
about each cell as well as saving ends
of the cell if we ran that same outcome
and we wanna go look and say hey what's
in your in your Google Cloud we just ran
that and actually the code I ran up
there was the exact same basically the
same code and then I point to this
papermill demo bucket and you can see we
have the outcome and the input separated
input has 993 bytes cuz it didn't happen
the image baked in and then the output
has 35 kilobytes because it was that
original notebook we looked at the
prints an image so how does this changed
the picture of you know the interaction
with the tooling under the hood like
this is sort of replacing this whole
stack not really it's actually just a
different client to talk to the jupiter
kernels so it's following the same
protocols and specs as an api client
would or any other kind of codified
interface you want to make or user
interface you want to make and because
jupiter has these really nice
about how to communicate between the
repple and the interface papermill can
act like any of those clients and
execute so when it runs it'll actually
launch a kernel manager which will go
find the kernel by name start it up run
all your code shut it down and then the
only other difference is that the read
and write were reading from one source
and writing to an outcome source
throughout some destination and that's a
little bit different than the maybe
development cycle pattern but the end of
the day you always have an IP miv URL
that you can load in any system if you
look a little deeper under the hood
about what this actually looks like
there's a few like modules that go in
here there's syncs and sources which can
be any kind of schema destination so
things like Google Cloud s3 as your file
system HTTP those are all baked in and
then the parameters here you can pass in
any kind of JSON like value and that's
extendable so if you want to have more
customized things for your platform it's
very easy to make an extension of how
the parameters get passed in so you
could do things like with table
references actually load the table data
on behalf of the user so the other thing
is kind of enables is the idea that you
might have a notebook template let's say
something that's a learning algorithm
and you want to you know adjust how you
actually run it you can run that and
parametrize the notebook differently for
each run and then you can run that
notebook and have a documented outcome
has visualizations logs and outcomes all
in one place for each parameter
variation from your template you started
with this is really really handy for
machine learning patterns because
oftentimes you want to have a template
explore a little bit find a pattern but
then you maybe don't know what
parameters you should excuse should
actually use in productions this is a
way you can fan out that notebook
without rewriting it along many
different parameters and the end result
here is you can also then kind of see
what the result of maybe a confusion
matrix or some other accuracy score on
the outcome is for each of those
notebooks so there's a few aspects of
notebook execution that this extends to
part of it is we've extended the use
case to other types of users and this is
actually where Netflix was really
targeting with some of this paper
investment before we just have the data
scientists have a nice like iteration
place that didn't fit very well into
production and now we actually have
expanded so now analytics engineers and
data engineers are using notebooks more
and more because they get the benefits
of sort of logging they get the benefits
of like associating the thing they're
executing to outcomes and they can kind
of iteratively develop they all kind of
an iteration cycle that looks somewhat
similar although to the data scientist
is the most involved in terms of
iteration cycles but now they can
develop in those notebooks and all of
those different user profiles can use
paper mills and then scheduled out on
the platform will run it
programmatically at a later time for
people so one example of this there was
a blog post which is linked on the slide
here around how to do how to use paper
mill with tensorflow on Google cloud to
actually execute your notebook with GPU
instances or other types of
configurations so here is just a little
snippet I had to cut a little short fit
in the slide but the blog has the full
code to execute this but you're
basically just going to run your Google
Cloud compute instance create call with
an instance and then you're gonna pass
in you know your GPU count and type and
then you're also gonna say hey my start
script is this papermill input path
output path and you could imagine adding
any kind of parameterization here and
that you would want and then you can
tell Google Cloud to delete that
instance when it's done and this
basically has now made a orchestration
for executing your notebook on top of
another enforcer network is another set
of hardware including hardware that you
might have access to a new local dev I
think to is like this is all open source
code so all the things showing are like
proprietary hid behind walls the Google
Cloud Storage was actually merged into
the open source so it's very easy for
anyone to access with their tooling in
the Google cloud s3 in Azure are similar
stories and it's really easily
accessible to any other scheme we want
to add we'll talk about how they do that
in a minute and the whole paper mill
repo which by the way had the 1.0
release actually went out today which is
like feature completeness and all the
like kind of little things upstream
finally got finished and Merson to
releases so it's a really nice clean
rebuild to read now but all of it is
plug-and-play
so how you
read from sinks and sources how you
actually execute the notebook and how
you apply parameters are all registered
classes that you can register your own
custom versions of say for example we
want to implement an SFTP handler say we
have some files in SFTP because that's
where someone has some notebooks or they
want their notebooks to land there
because we need to share it across some
b2b channel that still is using SFTP
the implement this would literally be
all the code on here if you implemented
read and write and then did the setup
tools here this would be all the code to
be able to call the command at the
bottom which is paper will execute with
an SFTP schema it has this entry points
pattern you could do where you can
register in your own setup PI an entry
point about how to register an i/o
interface in and for the other
interfaces of a similar pattern so the
code actually executes things if you
read the whole repo it's really short
now there's not very much code in there
so it's pretty easy to like grok ones
doing and to add new things all right so
one thing I want to talk about is
actually the failure mode is actually
really nice for notebooks traditionally
if you think of like how would I have a
bunch of scripts that maybe I didn't
quite productionize and put into a
library or maybe it's calling things
across three different systems how would
I actually understand what went wrong
when it fails and this is what keeps
people like me employed because it's a
hard problem so we can go build
solutions for people but one of the nice
things is with a notebook if you failed
with a notebook and we call that same
pattern we fan out over some parameter
the failed notebook actually has a
really rich source of what happened
how'd it go wrong well how do I
reproduce the problem you get all of
that captures in that notebook because
it failed it'll actually still save the
outcome but it'll say with here's the
stack trace here's the cell it failed
here's how the code didn't succeed and
your parameters when you're running the
papermill are already baked into that
notebook so you'll have to Reaper
amortize it it'll run exactly as it ran
when you were scheduled or running
inside a platform so here for example we
have this notebook these are some of the
advantages that just talk about stack
traces and rerun ability in execution
logs
but let's say that notebook we just had
we we failed and it crashed
well something go do is go find the
issue in the notebook say here we found
this cell execution number 12 I've cut
out middle Slayers has some sort of HTTP
connection failure talking to spark we
can go load that notebook into an up
into a notebook dev iterate on it until
we fix the problem and identify what's
actually wrong and then we can ship that
fix back to the upstream of notebook in
this case for example we had a spark job
as defaulting to a host name that didn't
exist so trying to target some yarn
cluster that doesn't exist so maybe we
need to tell it where the yarn cluster
actually is and now the job actually
succeeds and we can push that change up
but we reproduce the exact problem and
we didn't have to go and ask five
systems what went wrong so what these
kind of very simple change to how you
how you execute notebook with a client
that isolates the inputs and outputs
gives you is that you get immutable
inputs if you're not changing your input
that you've scheduled or are executing
on a programmatic basis immutable
outputs if you're saving your output to
unique path we can have a we've put to
whatever the user's execution context
plus a good for every single run and
then we associate that back and we put
it into some place where it's read-only
so users don't have access to go edit it
that means you have very good
reproducibility and audit history about
what actually executed
you also get nice parameterization of
notebook runs so no longer do you have
to have a big block of instructions for
the human to go change a notebook like
when running this change these three
lines in this cell and then go change
these four lines in the cell you know
what to do that anymore you can just
parameterize it and template eyes it so
the user can just pass in parameters and
then the other thing to do is the
configuration of sourcing and sinking
this means that you can get interface
right into the platforms we've already
share files or where you already have
hosted systems without having to rewrite
you know the execution and wrap it in
your own copy and move and shift so
given all that it also makes a pretty
compelling argument for being able to
test notebooks better with paper mill as
opposed to before or testing it was
usually ship at somebody and have them
run it and say yeah this is good and
hope they were right so in terms of
notebooks
one thing note when you're
talking about testing notebooks this
notebooks make pretty terrible libraries
they make great integration tools but if
you have a ton of library code in there
they're pretty hard to make reliable and
know that you could share and make you
for use and I'll talk about what that
means so they make a good integration
tool because no books are really good at
connecting different pieces of
technology logging how it actually ran
building a result or taking some actions
on on disparate pieces of technology
without having to leave an ecosystem but
they're kind of unreliable when they're
really complex or they have a really
high branching factor so when you have a
notebook that has you know 15
conditionals inside of it or many
different functions and loops it can be
really hard the reason about this thing
is gonna run the traditional path areas
with code is you would go unit test each
of those pieces and break them up with
notebook sense unit testings a bit hard
we actually kind of at least it Netflix
have adopted some of these developments
for the more critical things this is
keeping a low branching factor short and
simple is better try to keep the one
primary outcome so we have notebook
which has five things maybe consider
breaking out the five notebooks and have
five notebooks that do one each doing
its own job
and try to I put this in parenthesis
because we fail at it to leave library
functions and libraries so if you get a
really complex notebook and that's
important and you want to move
production move that code into a library
that's shared across your notebooks
maybe talk to your you know whoever's
helping support you to make that happen
if you don't know how but we do still
get an advantage of something we
couldn't do before with just integration
testing so if you want to write an
integration test you basically just want
to write exactly what the user would
have run a template call into your
notebook so say we have that smart
template that we showed failing earlier
we want to write an integration test
because it failed for the user because
they didn't have a cluster host defined
and we could have easily caught that
that the default value was gonna fail
here what we can do is run that same
spark template and then we're gonna do
some tests run output and maybe we would
automate this and you have a test run ID
in there and then what we're gonna do is
pass in a fake region the fake run day
and the debug flag just in case that
want to be able to maybe dry run their
execution if they're in debug mode
and in this case we're going to be
targeting this region has tons of users
called Luna its we're gonna pick a run
date maybe that doesn't really matter
we'll fix it to a hard-coded day really
is everyone awake by the way I just
talked about like cool finding people on
the moon and no one no one even okay
cool so we've got the here are
parameters you know that got passed in
you see region got signed the run date
got assigned and our debug true and in
here this sparks equal they were
actually running you know maybe it's
running a particular query against an
output table and now we using our
parameters we can like reorient how this
runs and running against dummy data so
we'll do this a lot we will run
integration tests and Netflix where
we'll run all the templates and we have
like default tables with some known like
potentially problematic patterns or just
the simplest thing we can make and then
we run the same template to usually
going to use in the same way they would
use by targeting that table or that
piece of code and this gives you like a
really nice way to say hey and the end
this notebook runs well I know all the
defaults make sense and I know I can
compare ammeter eyes it in some way you
can also if you have like a dag
execution you can do things like run the
integration test and then have a follow
up unit in your dag that says hey did
this actually write data if you're
concerned about that and you can kind of
branch
it gives right into the wheelhouse of
integration testing if you've ever kind
of dived in how QA thinks about testing
it gives a nice breadth of coverage for
notebooks in that space so it means it's
like what are some guidelines about how
I test my notebook unit testing your
notebook is hard the tooling out there
isn't great or even if you had good
tooling it's a little bit cumbersome
because how do you you have this one
document you could bundle and send to
somebody but now how do you bundle it
with unit tests you put them in your
notebook and make it really cluttered
you put it alongside then why don't you
just make a library anyway there's some
hard conversations there so we actually
up doing was saying hey use notebook
sort the good at which is integrations
or reproducibility and try to follow
these guidelines to make sure that you
can trust that they're gonna work if you
have like a simple one pager of a
notebook one integration test is
probably sufficient you'd be fine
if you have something that has maybe a
little complexity maybe it's two pages
of code
on your screen maybe a couple
integration tests for a few of the
patterns that could go through it to
make sure you cover all more of the
lines usually covers you pretty well and
you'll be pretty good for production use
cases if you do a really complex
notebook like I wrote my whole ml
training loading saving and three
different model iterations in the same
notebook and it's like a 20-page
document one maybe don't put that in
progress if it's critical move some of
that code into a library so that the
shared code between your model execution
can be loaded in all your notebooks and
then you don't look it nice and trim and
it's more about integration where your
library is one the integration pieces
and then if you can't do that and you
still need to get it running you know
trying to get one integration test per
usage pattern of how this would be used
at least gives you some confidence it's
not a silver bullet but it gets you
further and one thing I want really
emphasize too is that I've talked a lot
about paper mill and how you can use
this tool to change notebooks there's
actually a ton of other goodies in the
ecosystem because it's all spec and
protocol based notebooks actually have a
whole like rich environment of libraries
that give you different capabilities and
oftentimes in today's world a lot of
notebook teams are being formed or
really about how to collect these
goodies and put them into a platform
that works for your use cases so a lot
of tools that you probably haven't heard
of but are used by platform teams all
around that I would encourage looking to
do and be convert is something that
actually paper mail uses but it can have
other export form so you can make HTML
or PDF outcomes of your notebook
Commuter is a read-only interface for
notebooks probably the most useful out
of this list because it makes sharing a
lot safer and a lot easier you don't
have to have a whole notebook server up
just to share the results of an
execution or how you're planning to do
something there's a few others in here
so much I'll talk about for a couple
minutes
so scrapbook is one of them scrapbook is
another repo that I've written from
scratch that basically pulled some
functionality it was in the original
paper mill implementation and put it in
its own own bucket and what this is
really trying to do is as a tool
scrapbook is intended to kind of
complete the story arc of a notebooks as
a function so with paper mill now you
have an input notebook and you have
paper mills so you have like the funks
you're actually gonna run and you have
parameters as the inputs but your
outcome today is still a notebook so
when you outcome a notebook it's still
mostly human interpreter will not
machine interpret all one of the things
that this adds is the ability to save
results by name in your notebook and
then recall them and what this is really
useful for say I ran that notebook that
was an ml model and I want to iterate
all my parameters one of the things I
might want to save is like the confusion
matrix result and then I want to collect
all those computed matrices and find the
parameterization that was best or or fit
some criteria this lets you do that
pretty easily without leaving the
notebook I encourage you to look at the
github to like look at the more details
about how that works but here in this
example inside the notebook in the first
section we're importing scrapbook and
gluing our model results and then later
outside the notebook maybe after we've
executed every in another notebook
we're gonna read that outcome notebook
and then go collect the model result by
key and you can also save things like
graphs or recall them so one of the
things that's really handy is if you
have like a performance graph you can
actually save the performance graph
alongside your confusion matrix result
and then when you find the confusion
matrix you like the most you can
actually go render the graph for that
run as well and not have to re execute
it it's kind of a handy little tool take
a look it's a little bit early and sense
of where it could go but it has like
full feature capability for the things I
just described and I talked a little bit
that commuter really highly recommend
looking to this one this is the
interface or commuter this is our presto
template for how to execute presto jobs
notice it fits on one page it's nice and
clean there's almost nothing happening
but it's really handy because these
calls here we have like a schema input
and then we have you know a gaze here
that it prints out the job information
and a monitor at the end here we can
share this notebook template with users
and when they actually execute they'll
see this but parametrize with their logs
in there and we always share through
commuter to the users so they have a
really nice way of seeing what happened
without the risk of editing anything so
I've talked a lot about the open source
and kind of hinted about how we've used
it a lot one of the things at netflix in
about a year and a half ago when we kind
of started really diving into this
adventure there was a strategic bat made
that the large swath of users that we
have that we were hiring the most of
which were analysts were actually
using notebooks instead of other tools
that US leaning into making notebooks
easier would have benefit to the company
and then we kind of took it a little
further almost to crazy levels where we
were doing a new scheduler project we
decided to make every single scheduled
job be a notebook which might sound
extreme but actually it played that very
well is what we really did was we made
templates and the users didn't even know
they were using notebooks at first they
say I'm running a spark job I'm running
a transport to Druid they're just giving
the inputs and parameters for that type
of job that schema like any other job
definition but the end of the day we
always translate that to a notebook
because this may it so it's really easy
for anyone the debug what happened I'll
even put this the point we had a manager
of a team hadn't written code in a long
time and his on-call person this is a
machine learning team his on-call was
out sick and one of their critical jobs
failed and he he told me afterwards even
know he did this but he said oh yeah I
got paged because he was sick and I went
looked at the job and it had this
notebook thing I don't know what it was
I clicked on it and it had this really
nice visual and then it told me exactly
what the stacktrace air was and i read
it and i understood what was wrong and i
actually fixed it and then reran the job
and it worked right and like that was a
manager of a team was able to do that
like the lowers the barrier quite a bit
on understanding like what actually
happened and what went wrong um so
that's kind of a fun thing and since
then since we saw this project we we've
moved like over 10,000 jobs that produce
like on the order of 150,000 queries a
day to all be running in this notebook
framework and we've had pretty good
success being able to support that well
that's why I have for the presentation
and then I think we have some time for
questions but yeah
yes so the question was is there any
difference between running pure Python
and running a Python notebook the answer
is pretty much no in reality this is all
the only thing you have is a little bit
of startup time in order to launch the
kernel just on the order of you know a
second or two and then after that you're
running Python code with ipython at the
same way you would run Python code
normally so there's no real performance
impact the kernel is responsible for
making sure it can execute the code so
in most cases like in the Python case
it's wrapping ipython so it's launching
a process ID it's built in yeah often
times people for like version things
like Python or Scala or some other or R
if you're using it they'll name their
kernels with the version so you'll say I
am an i python version 3.7 kernel right
so you know you're running Python 37
that's the standard you're executing
it's much like you would say hey execute
this job with Python 37 same way with
skull and others in SPARC they'll
oftentimes put the version in the
metadata of the kernel so it's very
clear what you're executing against how
it chooses the kernel is actually inside
the notebook it saves when you run it or
you connect to a kernel it saves in the
metadata of the notebook I ran on this
kernel when it runs it tries to find
exactly that kernel and then it has
fallback mechanisms if it can't to try
best-effort if you want sorry are you in
the new
yeah so what was the alternative to
doing what we're doing with notebooks
now well one is we have a really old
scheduler and it was a real pain to
debug it there were like two guys who
could do it everyone else was like hey
this went wrong and those two guys got
really really busy so on the scheduling
side that was the story was kind of like
unscalable for the what we had we could
have solved it in other ways on the kind
of iterative cycle and like moving
things the prod side of things with
notebooks the story was the story that's
a lot of places today which is every
time you wrote something in notebook
after you got done you got told to go
rewrite that someplace else and
sometimes you did a good job with that
and sometimes you threw it over the wall
data engineering and sometimes they did
it and sometimes they threw it back at
you so there was kind of a lot of
friction and it was okay and at a
certain scale but we were clear seeing
the warning signs that like there's the
user base that's doing this is growing
way faster than all the other user bases
so rather than running away from the
technology they like and use we wanted
to move the platform closer to them so
there was less friction at the back
there sorry he's got add up a couple of
yeah so the question is there is there a
limit on the computation within the
kernel it has the same limits as any
other execution process so oftentimes
you're executing when you schedule this
or run us on platform you're running
usually in some container that has some
resource limits and those are your
limits it's the same as any other
process
no I saves everything it just it's an
output totally it's it but it does when
it runs it actually reads the IP MIB
it's a JSON schema so it loads IP MIB
file in verifies it matches the schema
for version 4.4 then executes it in
memory against it updating and every
time it saves it converts that in memory
representation to an output totally
independent of the input so it'll
actually dump it today every time you
save you're saving the whole notebook so
that's something that will probably
change in notebook five format with some
options for being a little more scalable
in that sense usually it's not a problem
unless you save really really big
displays like I save a gigabyte of data
you're gonna have a bad like if you just
say print and it's a gigabyte you're
gonna have a really bad time of course
you'd have a bad time in most interfaces
but it's a little worse in notebooks in
that sense but yeah every time you save
it saves a whole document the question
over there
yeah I would encourage you to bring some
of those tools to notebooks there are a
few like linting and and like a lot of
UI is Hopson built-in stuff around
certain languages though since it's a
polyglot system a lot of those languages
lack nice and nice autocompletes nice
like linters and things like that so if
you jump over to something like Scala
still kind of rough it's getting made
better because there's companies
investing in it but like our our studio
still does better than our and Jupiter
in that sense I would say those tools
can be integrated and I would encourage
to bring those tools to Jupiter there's
a few places where they already exist
all right yeah a bunch of good I think
you were next yeah so he's talking about
the question was when things go wrong
like the kernel runs out of memory what
happens or is it handled well well nice
thing is a paper mill 1.08 released it
now has a better om handler so it'll
actually raise that it ran out of memory
instead of running forever which it used
to do sometimes just the worst thing it
did out of things they were bad but in
terms of like story arc what'll happen
is when you actually run is it won't
save that final execution you'll see if
you load the notebook it'll say
executing the paper mill dot dot dot and
it'll be stuck in that mode most things
the processes die me don't know how to
recover but what you do get is when you
run paper mill we run in production we
run with - log outputs and that says
every time we would get a message we
were buffering the same in the notebook
we log it out right there so we at least
have the container that was executing
paper mill has all the logs so if
something really catastrophic happens we
can always read the logs from there even
if the cell and the notebook failed one
thing would be nice and I think maybe we
should probably invest that more and in
our platform is when it does out out of
memory of making a link like rewriting
over that notebook to add a link back to
the logs or inject the logs afterwards
it doesn't do that today but it would be
pretty easy to add
cool yeah so question was do you save in
version control and how do you dip it
the answer is I save my stuff in version
control not everyone else does I would
say that dipping is kind of painful it's
been getting better actually there's a
few tools out there so MB dime is that
there's a tool in Jupiter for dipping
notebooks it's not so integrated would
get everywhere but there's some efforts
there and B viewer is a nice it's kind
of got an open-source side in a closed
source side if you're doing github
viewing and I encourage you to go if you
don't use github they've got issues for
other get systems that I've definitely
plus one go poke them and tell stash or
I mean bitbucket to go add an API so you
can do the right thing in terms of local
dippin so the reason why I asked this
notebook dipping is really ugly because
you're dipping JSON documents they are
pretty printed at least so it's not like
all one line but when you want to read
as a human you usually give up after a
bit so the effort with NB dime and other
places to get integration to your like
places where you do code reviews and
render the notebook as a different
two-sided diff rather than reading the
JSON ROM today I read the JSON raw
sometimes and so fortunate you had a
follow-up questions yeah um some of
that's just like like the analysts and
even some of the data scientists like
gets a new thing like they may be just
like sequel they can do reporting they
know tableau they know some of the
interfaces it gets kind of new so it's
kind of a scary thing to get into and
also sometimes people are just lazy
because humans are humans so like while
yes you should always use git in version
control the reality is sometimes people
skip that step if they don't think it's
too important and then later it becomes
important they forgot to do that what we
are trying to do there there's one of
the tools I mentioned there's called
book store books or tries to give you
linear versioning so every time you save
it kicks off a version two right now it
doesn't the s3 blast me in this room for
Google Cloud you can plug it in make it
make it happen but book store is a way
to get to some linear version control
without having the user have to do
anything yeah
yeah and be convert - to Python now oh
sorry the question for anyone that was
online I couldn't hear was can you
convert in a notebook into a Python with
regular price on file and any comparison
the tool to do that yeah the question
was are Jupiters open source can anyone
contribute do we have like donations
please or a big don't enter sign no we
don't so I'm on the Jupiter team as well
and yes we try to be as friendly as we
can to pull people in there are a few of
the packages or code paths that you know
could use some more professional look so
we do trial so I'll try and tag issues
with like you new new user friendly
papermill has had a lot of like brand
new contributors contribute to paper
mail specifically my fact that's
actually how Google Cloud they just kind
of opened up a PR and said hey we really
love to get Google cloud working with
this and that went really easy so I
would say it's open and there's a lot of
forums both long discourse Gitter and
the google group are all good places to
kind of engage if you trying to find a
place to work and then interact also has
a slack channel for lots of things you
can go ask questions there
as a URL parameter like go fetch them
from a URL not sure I quite follow the
question yeah oh I see so he's asking
when you load a notebook in the UI can
you add query parameter parameters your
notebook no cuz that's not actually
running through the templating path at
all that's like the UI human path
there'll probably be extensions to make
it easy like some of the interfaces now
actually just made like add a notebook
parameter cell as like a first class
thing into the notebook interface where
you just click a button then it you know
builds a cell for you though
traditionally today what you have to do
is so the way it will choose where the
put your parameters and how to apply
them is it'll look for a cell with the
cell tag parameters and you'll treat
that as the default so anything in there
thinks are the defaults and then will
inject a fact doesn't find anything
you'll just put it at the top but from a
query parameter point of view it's not
really the interface your parameterizing
there because you would just write the
code cell yourself or write the default
tag cell yourself it doesn't
automatically do that for you
feature request was can you add
something so you can keep track of how
long sales took to execute your on the
paper mill that does that basically the
question was if a colonel fails and your
your paper mill execution stops could
you reattach the colonel and and run
against it today with tools as is it
would not do that because it shuts down
the colonel when it fails more into
temps too because it kind of may already
be dead
you could you could write some code it
would probably take on the order of 50
100 lines of code to make it not do that
and actually that extension part where I
said where you can plug and play the
iosing so I guess FTP you could also
plug a play a thing called engines so it
has the ability to register custom
execution engines and you could register
a custom engine that would hold on like
you could monkey patch the overwrite the
way MB converts on the kernel and like
not shut it down so maybe have like a an
engine called debug or interrupt and
then you could run that version of the
engine when you execute and then you
could leave it up so you could reconnect
it would be a little complicated from an
interface point of view but it's
physically possible in the out of the
box doesn't get that
yes the question was in the architecture
diagram there's the stupider servers who
runs these servers what do they do who
owns them okay the answer is usually a
notebooks platform team so many many
places have a notebook steam Google does
here Netflix does most your big vendors
do they're usually the ones who are
hosting the servers that are that are
running everything and figuring out with
the rest of platform how to orchestrate
that so how to isolate resources or on
demand this is a few tools in the open
source that help you with this like
Jupiter hub as a way of dipping out
things and I think that's a pretty
rapidly evolving story but generally
it's usually a notebook platform team
that's managing the servers and then
when you click launch my notebook or you
try to load a notebook into like
dynamically allocate resources for you
someplace depends on the platform some
platforms you have dedicated resources
are shared resources it kind of lets you
do it your platform things to the right
also I don't love people are on the
remote call and want to ask questions if
that's possible or people okay
yeah so the paper mill on the Jupiter
side basically Shanaya so it's very easy
for any scheduling tool that has daga
execution to do its job well which is
doing DAGs and linking things together
so we use an internal schedule tool that
we've beefed up and we basically have
two job types we have run a container
and run a container with paper mill
that's like the two job types but in
reality from the user perspective we
have like many templates that we default
in for them but there we really leave it
on the tool that knows how to schedule
not knowing what paper mill is and just
executing doing that job well so like an
open source example that has air flow if
you have air flows very easy to
integrate paper mill and air flow a lot
of people do it that they're luigi or
some of the other schedulers can do it
very easily too but others I would say
in change of responsibilities I would
let schedulers do scheduling well and
dagga X here's through daga executing
well and paper mill do the execution
well
yeah so the question was with the
different personas we have what's the
lifecycle of a notebook with each of
those personas or the handed offer and
the end depends more actually on the
team or how that organization operates
so the tooling we've built kind of spans
a bunch of orgs at Netflix most of the
time people own in the end I would say
like they write on the notebook and then
they want to schedule it and then we ask
them to kind of follow some guidelines
or like if you want to burn yourself and
do something bad you can we kind of have
a hands-off approach at Netflix so it's
a little different than some places I
would say a few teams and probably more
the iteration cycle outside of Netflix
is probably more the handoff model which
is the traditional model hopefully this
tool link helps to lower that friction
some so the handoff is more like review
and do more like a code review and then
template izing it rather than rewriting
someone's work entirely yes so Google
collab isn't Jupiter follows the Jupiter
specs so if you have a collab notebook
you go wrong with paper mill and you can
load it in any other notebook interface
it's a Jupiter notebook interface collab
by the way if you're not aware is like
the one of the Google provided notebook
interfaces for managing notebooks
inside a Google cloud oh that's like
Google Cloud but inside Google
is there a better visualization tool for
video in notebooks um there's a few
efforts of in there it's more about the
component it renders so the way if you
actually look at what's being sent as
messages to and from the kernel they
actually you send code to execute and
then asynchronously you get back these
reasons like different messages one of
the messages is called display and
display has a mime type much like any
other like front-end rendering system
would understand so then your UI can
implement mime type renders so you can
implement a nice like a better video
render about anything by implementing
something that responds to that mime
type and then plugging that to the video
editor player you like so there's been
some efforts and a few UI is it making
better video mostly those have been
closed source extensions of Jupiter not
so much in the open source I'm not aware
what the current state is for open
source video rendering niceties but if
you want to add a component that's easy
for all of them to use I'm encouraged
looking at the interact project in the
interact that's like a collection of
react components that are made to be
used in different notebook UI front ends
it's really easy to have a new bind type
renderer
yeah so the question was around how do
we come to decision of you know
branching on the notebook level instead
of maybe branching within the notebook
and then dividing and that actually he's
kind of been I can't see it is there's
two design philosophies but how
notebooks would evolve one of them was
the notebook as like a black box like
function that I'm gonna execute or some
larger system going to execute and the
other was the idea that each cell would
be that functional unit and then you
would reuse the cell somehow Netflix
ended up leaning on the notebook side
because it was simpler so the kiss hit
model kept it easier to reason about it
doesn't mean the other model is wrong or
couldn't be built but we kind of built
tools for what we saw as the path of
least resistance that would have the
most reliability one of the issues with
trying to one of the opinions paper male
takes is you're gonna run this notebook
linearly notebooks don't require you to
do that from the UI side but paper mill
does and this simplifies the problem and
the reproducibility question a bit and
the other model how you execute your
cells it becomes almost an acyclic graph
of execution of your different cells and
notebooks didn't have a great way to
express that dag within notebooks today
so if we went that route where you want
to like iterate on exiting a cell
probably would have pushed more on
building tooling around like setting up
a dag around inside the notebook object
about how you're going to execute your
cells and how they relate better but we
didn't go that way because I felt it was
more complicated at the time
yes the question was how do you onboard
people under these best practices and
how do you make their best practices
actually best practices instead of maybe
best practices um that's really like I
can give you the Netflix answer I don't
think it'll translate to a lot of other
places and it's not perfect I think in
the Netflix case we lean a lot on this
concept of freedom or responsibility so
teams individuals are free to do
whatever they kind of want but we expect
that we've hired experienced people that
are going to make responsible decisions
so oftentimes within org that org or
that team has made decisions about how
to best onboard people and so we we try
to provide the tools and notify like
inform people that these tools and
patterns and documentation or someplace
then we leave the responsibility on the
teams to figure out which of these they
should keep track of and onboard their
users with there's some centralized
onboarding like we do training about the
scheduler and notebooks for new hires
every month and and for people who just
don't know what it is so we do a little
bit of the training model and try to
follow that way it works pretty well
within our culture but within other
cultures you might want to do a
different approach cool I get to save my
voice then awesome I'm not sure where we
are on time okay yeah so the question
was around why separate the notebook
when it goes to production because the
data science lifecycle lives within the
same notebook that's how they operate
now I have to think about two notebooks
that exist in a while there's a couple
reasons we did this one is it made data
platforms be okay with us doing this so
you can't that's one of them it's
actually a really compelling thing is
like crosses a bridge where you give
this a mutability guarantee about I ran
this source and it resulted in this
outcome so from like a pure execution
independent what it's doing that gives a
lot of nice like security and
replayability and debug ability for
people who are outside of knowing what
your notebook actually did or how it
should operate so that's one aspect the
other aspect we have is that we wanted
to have a very good recollection of how
your notebook change over time or how it
would iterate it last time so many times
if something fails in the platform
engineer someone tries to help they have
to go look at what ran and figure out
what why it didn't work and knowing what
the last successful version is is really
handy because you can go look at the
last successful run compare it with the
current run that can tell you a lot of
things about why something isn't working
now how does that feed back in like as a
model or like how do you have a template
one thing that happens as a development
side if you schedule something we take
as a parameterization usually when you
want to try playing with it you want
that same parameterization so many times
people in the data science cycle would
schedule a notebook run it and there you
go see how it ran and either they'll
just copy the parameter cell back and
run it because it's the same source or
they'll copy the whole notebook
and then when they're done they'll just
delete the parameter cell and save it so
they're in the cycle is a little bit
manual still there could be tooling to
make it less manual and I think that's
where a lot of tooling is going is
smoothing over these edges it's a little
bit of a bump for a really big win to be
cooperative for the rest of the
ecosystem does that help answer the
question awesome obviously my voice and
I'll be around so maybe I'll lose it
anyway but thank you everyone and hope
you enjoyed